land und brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen sichert die
hamburger morgenpost wo er reiche dich
heute habe ich lange nicht mehr gefragt
ja stimmt ja und tatsächlich in der
altbekannten kemenate oder mit anderen
worten im prinzip
ja ich hätte ich hab' ich habe heute ein
herrliches thema für dich ich habe lange
überlegt was machen wir heute um mir ist
aufgefallen dass du ja mit zunehmendem
alter immer reaktionärer wirst ja immer
konservativer so richtig konservativer
knochen oder habe ich gedacht auch noch
die langen haare als tarnung genau
richten auch um etwas vorzutäuschen was
das schon lange nicht mehr ist deswegen
habe ich gedacht wir hofreiter
herumreiten dass auch tarnung ja genau
inzwischen ist das tano tagung passt gut
zu ihm
markus söder hat ihm neulich empfohlen
sich endlich mal ordentlichen
haarschnitt zu verpassen ach ich meine
markus söder ja also der inbegriff eines
ordentlichen happen hasen
dabei ist lustiger weise das etwas was
ich an markus söder immer mochte dass
ihm die frisur immer so ziemlich scheiß
egal war er hatte mit seiner haare so
dass er sich einmal im jahr zu einem
großen kostümball als alles mögliche
verkleiden konnte gerne und lange haare
immer gestört
und ich fand das aber immer cool dass
das dass das markus söder sun haare
einfach so trägt wie sie so wachsen wie
sie sein denn der jetzt mit zum spruch
kommt so nach dem motto die langhaarigen
sollen sich endlich eine vernünftige
frisur zulegen er als wahlparteitag
hatte muss um eine nach ausbauen aber
eigentlich komme ich jetzt von markus
söder zu queen das ist jetzt die grosse
frage alleinherrscher
autokraten
alles alles gar nicht alles streng
demokratisch aber ja nicht unbedingt
strengen demokratisch aber ich wollte
ich erst mal frankreich queen also die
ganze welt ich musste ganz ehrlich sagen
ich meine wir betrauern den tod an der
96 jahre alten dame ja und es sei ihr
von herzen gegönnt dass sie so alt
geworden ist aber jetzt kann man noch
nicht sagen plötzlich und unerwartet das
war dieser tod nicht und alle sind
trotzdem bis ins mark erschüttert
und und und alle sind furchtbar traurig
und selbst leute die sie in ihrem leben
nie gesehen haben und sicher am meisten
sind furchtbar gerührt sein wahnsinn
also wie soll es weitergehen was was
geht dir denn als neue märz
konservativen durch den kopf wächst ja
also ich glaube dass es den menschen
darum geht in dem moment zu verstehen
was geschichte ist dabei die queen bei
immer schon da und wenn so etwas was
immer schon da es verschwindet dann hat
man plötzlich das gefühl dass
unglaublich viel zeit vergangen ist und
das interessante an der clean ist für
mich du weißt ja ich bin ja
passionierter zoologe und es gibt ja so
dünnes eis yesil ja es gibt so tiere es
gibt tiere die passen eigentlich nicht
mehr in unsere zeit aber die gibt es
seit jahrmillionen trocken ja das
berühmteste beispiel dafür ist die
brücke next die stammt aus der zeit der
dinosaurier oder denkmal an diese
galapagos schildkröte lonesome george
war ja die die letzte galapagos
schildkröte dieser unterart und er war
150 und noch mehr jahre alt also noch
deutlich älter als die queen ja und alle
fanden es total traurig dass aber ich
auch ehrlich war sie der letzte seiner
art war und ich denke immer das ist mit
der queen so ein bisschen ähnlich wie
mit lonesome george ja also irgend ein
wesen das eigentlich gar nicht mehr in
unsere zeit gehört ja aber unglaublich
alt also märchenhaft erhält also ich
glaube dass es viele erinnern da gibt
die haben die queen für unsterblich
gehalten
oder die hätte auch 150 sein können die
hat sich auch in den letzten jahrzehnten
optisch nicht mehr verändert und das hat
irgendwas dass man das gefühl hat dass
so was was eigentlich man die queen was
überhaupt nicht mehr in unsere zeit
gehört dass das trotzdem aber noch da
ist also genauso wie die galapagos
schildkröte und die brücken wechsel okay
das finde ich super und um noch im
vergleich zu machen ja hier geht es
genauso mit dem papst obwohl der papst
häufiger gewechselt hat aber das ist
noch päpste gibt im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert also was was es seit 2000
jahren gibt
ja in unserer heutigen modernen
materialistischen
kapitalistischen welt noch so was ja
also so eine metaphysische instanz ist
so erstaunt nicht dass man sich denkt
mein gott wie bei der brücken exe ja
alle kamen und gingen und das
ausgerechnet dass das dritte mal die
queen liest auch so sein aber
ausgerechnet das ist übrig geblieben
also ausgerechnet in england wo man
schon mal könig geköpft hat ja teil den
ersten ja also wo im grunde genommen als
erstes die monarchie gestürzt wurde hat
immer noch ja diese institution ja und
den papst gibt es noch also das finde
ich ich weiß nicht ich finde es
irgendwie gut dass es so was der papst
die englische königin und die brücken
exe und galapagos george also der ja
unser genau kann auch das ist so für
mich ich glaube so in meinem gehirn ja
im gleichen neuronalen cluster
gespeichert das ist so diese kontinuität
das ist das was du magst und das ist die
kontinuität und das ist die gegenwart
von etwas was eigentlich in die
vergangenheit gehört aber irgendwie
unsterblich zu sein scheint weißt du
woran ich gerade denken musst
du kennst monaco franze
großartig finde ich auch raus war völlig
wieder reingehen und akku franz so
großartig und es gibt eine szene da
sitzt monaco mit dem kopf lag man in der
polizeikantine und die essen zu mittag
und
der kopf money sagte monaco
monaco das essen dies ist immer anders
aber die chance dies immer gleich
und dann kommt der großartige satz
vergisst man da steckt der unheimliche
kontinuität drin
[Gelächter]
ja das ist das ist die queen war schon
das ist wie das ist die immer gleiche
soße weil ich nicht wechseln
premierminister und so weiter er alle
kommen und gehen und die queen blieb
deswegen ist das vielleicht so
merkwürdig dass man tatsächlich so das
gefühl hatte dass die wird immer bleiben
ja ich glaube dass ganz viele engländer
das auch an und jetzt räche ich meine
lanze dafür jetzt könnte man ja sagen ok
man kann das jetzt sagen wir mal so
sehen als grotesk das ist das noch gibt
aber es ist ja immer die frage ob super
uns in letzter zeit wird die ganz häufig
gestellt was hält unsere gesellschaft
zusammen ja was ist das narrativ
was was garantiert noch irgendwie in
einer zeit in der der individualismus so
ausgeprägt ist manche sagen der egoismus
ja was was fast gibt es da noch was
irgendwie eine nation zusammenhält oder
volk oder so und ich denke in ihm
zusammen machen hat die queen eine
positive rolle gespielt manchmal durch
nichtstun um hatte ich mal durch nicht
einmischen vielleicht einfach durch
immer schon da sein ja also ich weiß
nicht ob die rolle so schwierig ist aber
sie hat das verkörpert und das ist nicht
nichts
ja aber es ist auch nicht viel sicher
ich habe ich nicht für die briten war es
wahrscheinlich schon viel ja
wahrscheinlich ist das so aber ist
wahrscheinlich so dass david
psychologisiert und so weiter und so die
sehnsucht nach stabilität und der anker
ich meine ganz ehrlich als ich in meinem
leben war die queen auch immer da und
und und dieses dann wird danach davon
geschwärmt welches vertrauen diese frau
so verströmte usw und die war sozusagen
der trost in schweren zeiten also dass
ich damals vor diesem geldautomaten
stand hamburger sparkasse und dieser
automaten eine karte einzog also ich
weiß die queen war da nicht der hand hat
mir geholfen sagte ich jetzt mal so kann
sich auch kein engländer ja
auch ganz viele bei der wahl claim bank
oder so dem konto und ich sag dir hat
ich muss in diesen tagen so viel darüber
nachdenken was ist eigentlich besser ich
meine okay die haben die queen wir haben
frank walter steinmeier ja ja und ich
sag dir wenn ich mal anfangen so richtig
darüber nachzudenken dann über die queen
dann steinmeier steinmeier jetzt ja weit
ihr enorm gespannt weil weil das
natürlich etwas ist diese diese ganze
monarchie wenn du dich mal anfangs mit
diesem thema zu beschäftigen
dann stehst du auf dinge und dann ist da
nix mehr mit süßen nette kleine frau die
lustige runde hat die irgendwelche pudel
mit irgendwelchen anderen gekreuzt hat
die überall hinpassen durften auf jeden
königlichen teppich und so weiter und
dann wurde das in die weg gemacht gibt
es ja irrsinnige szenen diese diese
dieses gibt der böse zungen sagen sie
hat ihre hunde mehr geliebt als ihre
eigenen kinder ja und das ist alles
skurril das verstehe ich alles und diese
frau hatte eine schöne ausstrahlung der
da gehe ich absolut mit aber dieses
dieser dieser irrsinnige reichtum der da
ist auf der einen seite diese
irrsinnigen privilegien wenn du diese
britische gesellschaft auch kennst wir
haben 2009 10 uns da mal länger
aufgehalten für eine reportage kann man
immer noch sehen in der zdf mediathek
man da mal reingeht england ungeschminkt
und schaust dir das mal an dann stellst
du fest england das ist ein kastensystem
ja das ist das ganze land ist in der
hand weniger großgrundbesitzer und der
größte grossgrundbesitzer ist die queen
zu dem absurden recht dass jedes stück
land in großbritannien das nicht
irgendjemandem gehört gehört automatisch
der queen wusstest du dass das ist
verrückt wenn es irgendeinen
quadratmeter land gibt wo keiner sagt ok
gehört mir damit besser automatisch war
ist sowas überhaupt noch übrig das kann
ich ihnen auch nicht vorstellen ich frag
mich wo ist mir jemand begegnet das
keinem so richtig gehört aber ist das
nicht bei uns genauso dann gehört dem
staat oder dann gehört wahrscheinlich
der den gehört dem staat genau und ich
war mal auf den äußeren hebriden
das sind so eine inselgruppe vor
schottland ich weiß nicht ob da mal war
es wahrscheinlich habe ich davon schon
mal erzählt das war so eine wahnsinnig
schöne reise endet und das leben
deutlich mehr schafe als menschen und so
und da wir so einen typen getroffen der
erstaunlich gut deutsch sprach ich
dachte hey wie congstar ist er so gut
deutsch spricht und fragt ihn ob man in
deutschland war dann sagte er ja den
70er jahren und sagte ich okay wo warst
du ja das wollte ja nicht sagen und dann
stellte sich heraus er war in berlin und
ich sagte ja ostberlin und da sagte yao
kann es sein dass du agent warst und er
sagte ich habe keine ahnung
denn der auf den äußeren hebriden jetzt
irgendwelche schafe züchtet aber dieses
diese privilegien diese leute genießen
das ist wahnsinn meint jetzt nicht die
agenten sondern mainz die königin ich
meine die königin während und sozusagen
alles was da nicht es gibt ja sozusagen
in diese englische gesellschaft ist er
wirklich so aufgebaut also gehst nach
iten und da gehst du ganz viel rudern
und dann gehst und nach oxford und da
lernst du debattieren und studierst auch
um dann weiter und haben genau und dann
bruders du direkt über die themse bis
nach westminster dann sitzt du auch dem
parlament und dann wirst du idealerweise
premierminister ja also so ist es
logisch dass vor allem gelaufen ja und
so läuft das in alten demokratien in
demokratien die nicht wie deutschland
erstmal sehr spät eine wirkliche
geworden sind und zweitens wo die
gesellschaft komplett kanalisiert worden
ist durch den ersten von zwei möglichen
ja aber dann ja also so kann über diesen
ja also alles wurde sozusagen
durcheinander geworfen weil ich meine
ich ist hat hier nicht jeder 40 mark
oder so auf der hand da als die
bundesrepublik gegründet wurde nach der
währungsreform es gab auch leute die
hatten großen grundbesitz und manche
leute hatten auch vorrücken diese wieder
aufbauen konnten aber insgesamt war das
für viele leute zurück auf los und das
hat es so weder in england noch in
frankreich gegeben das stimmt und dann
wird eine eine gesellschaft automatisch
durch die ganz natürlichen kräfte wenn
man da politisch nicht gegensteuert
zusammengedrückt wie eine sanduhr und
das erleben wir in frankreich und das
erleben wir in england und wir haben oft
darüber gesprochen tendenzen dazu gibt
es bei uns auch und ist unglaublich
wichtig da gegenzusteuern und die
englische gesellschaft ist enorm fragil
genau wie die französische gesellschaft
auch genau
und es ist halt die frage nach dem wesen
der demokratie
was ist also ist vieles nicht in
wahrheit auch dann die illusion von
demokratie wenn du ich hatte etwas sehr
oligarch übrigens die allermeisten
demokratien ja italien ist auch so ne
ist auch
genau gibt es gibt so wenige verlassen
wenn wir so etwas gibt das land so stück
für stück über die weltkarte gehen und
uns alle demokratien angucken dann das
ist immer noch eine frage ob sie mehr
oder weniger stark oligarchischen nimmt
und da kann man über deutschland sagen
natürlich gibt es auch organische
ansätze in deutschland aber wir sind
deutlich geringer als in frankreich sind
und in england sind aus dem vorhin
genannten grund genau wenn du da mal
rein gehst richard es gibt diesen crown
estate ja das ist so ein fonds sozusagen
geht zurück auf 80 jahrhundert ja das
gehört technisch gesehen gehört dass
weder dem monarchen noch dem staat aber
da ist sozusagen alles drin was die
annan besitz haben also zumindest das
was offiziell besitz ist und wenn ich
das mal liest was da alles dazu gehört
das ist wahnsinn zum beispiel die
komplette regions street in london
diese berühmte einkaufsstraßen er hat
einfach komplett windsor castle ganz
ganz viele immobilien 116 tausend hektar
land das ist so groß wie hamburg und
wieder geschlossen wird der buckingham
palace der königlichen familie ich nehme
man ja ok gehört zu diesem crown estate
soweit ich das weiß ok und bei moral
kassel dass bolivar besitzt das ist
privatbesitz der königin genau dein
schottland und dieser crown estate er
hat einen wert von ungefähr 17
milliarden euro
erwirtschaftet im jahr 2021 fast 400
millionen und die queen kriegt davon 25
prozent also 95,5 millionen euro ließ er
etwas auch nur zum thema privilegien
dieser prozentsatz wir 2027 wieder auf
15 prozent gesenkt
der war vor zehn jahre von parlamenten
nur deswegen erhöht worden damit die
queen die renovierung von buckingham
bezahlen kann ja solche privilegien oder
zum beispiel wo hast du denn gehören
alle wilden krustentiere in schottland
eine unverschämtheit
es heißt du kannst keine huma daraus
ziehen sondern der wird beschlagnahmt im
namen der königin so genau also den
gehören auf jeden fall alle wilden
krustentiere in schottland wirklich eine
da gibt es diese die firma das ist ja
das ist eigentlich eine bezeichnung für
die königsfamilie selbst
mit dem tod der queen besteht dieses
unternehmen und jetzt nur noch auf
sieben personen gehört jetzt charles der
dritte also ja die artist formerly known
as prince dazu dann camilla william und
kate dann prinzessin
und edward und seine frau sophie die
verwalten dieses mega unternehmen allein
die immobilien in der königlichen firma
haben einen wert von acht milliarden
euro dazu gehört buckingham kensington
cornwall das gesamte herzogtum und
lancaster ja das musst du dir vorstellen
unvorstellbar 8 milliarden euro obwohl
es kommt
die verwalten alle einnahmen alles was
sozusagen aus offiziellen einnahmen
kommt kassieren die ein lizenzieren zum
beispiel logos also wenn irgendwelche
logos irgendwo drauf stehen auf
irgendwelchen getränken zum beispiel
irgendwo drauf kommt dann gibt das jedes
mal kohle und es hat einen echten werten
also wenn du auf der flasche bier ein
königliches warten drauf druckst dann
sagen experten gibt es dafür ungefähr
zehn prozent mehr umsatz also das lohnt
sich richtig dann gibt es den previews
das ist sozusagen die geheime geldbörse
das ist nur das herzogtum lancaster das
wird so bezeichnet es riesig groß 200
quadratkilometer hat eine tolle
küstenlinie jährliche einnahmen von 24
millionen euro
die einnahmen aus der firma ungefähr 500
millionen euro also da kommt so viel
geld zusammen das das kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen dann kommen diese diese
privaten besitztümer dazu gehört eben
bei moral da wo sie jetzt gestorben ist
private kunstsammlung als ihre mutter
gestorben ist hat die queen angeblich 70
millionen euro geerbt und sie müssen
glaube ich keine erbschaftssteuer zahlen
also das haben die das ist der
entscheidende punkt im handel
ausgehandelt klar da wirklich könig
silos nicht verarmt so damit genau 40
prozent erbschaftssteuer werden für die
nicht fällig ich frage dich warum naja
wenn das jetzt von generation zu
generation mit einer richtig großen
erbschaftssteuer ist dann würde das ja
wie butter in der sonne unter schmelzen
jetzt hast du mitleid oder was aber ich
versuche gerade in erklärung dafür zu
finden ja ja die erklärung verstehe ich
auch es gibt es gibt da geht's um
skurrile sachen wusstest du zum beispiel
dass alle unmarkierten schwäne auf der
themse gehören auch der queen
mit den krustentieren wirklich früheren
eigentlich wäre das ist der dass
ausgehandelt hat in welcher zeit das war
zu zeiten eher adwords des dritten sich
das nachgelesen
1350 reden wir ja da kostet ist ein
schwan zehnmal so viel wie alle ganz die
wurden gegessen ja weil die bis zu 20
kilo schwer werden können und deswegen
war so ein schwan halten echter wert
heute wären die nur noch gezählt es ist
skurril alle unmarkierten schwäne auf
der themse gehören einfach dem das war
so ähnlich gewalt oder so also quasi
natürliche ressource für hunger leiten
damit der könig immer genug schweine zu
essen hat so genau ich frag mich
übrigens nur am rande hast du jemals
schwan gegessen wie kann das sein dass
man heute kein schwein mehr ist
also man ist enten gänse oder man ist
keine schwäne und wenn die früher so
bist unser besondere delikatessen waren
aus welchem grund ist das mal ist er
selbst habe in der zeit über die wir
gesprochen haben da kostet es um schwans
himmel so viel wie nie ganz ja das war
eine absolute liegt ist das wahnsinnig
lecker gewesen ja
und brings leute auf ideen lieber nicht
ja ja ich mache es gibt ja hier
düsseldorf viele wilde schwäne genau
wird bestimmt morgen frank walter
steinmeier ja bei uns gehören die frank
walter steinmeier im bundestag ok und
dann ist gesteht eine ganz hohe strafe
auf schweine wildern kenner und charles
jetzt noch mal schön oben drauf habt
jetzt nochmal den privatbesitz seiner
mutter geschätzte 500 millionen euro
ohne erbschaftssteuer ist das okay jetzt
sehe ich das mal rum diary
sozialdebatte hier mal an die genau wenn
du jetzt morgen england regieren würde
und du hättest auch jede erdenkliche
parlamentsmehrheit die du brauchst was
würdest du daran ändern ich sag mal so
also ob wenn du das mit der demokratie
ernst nimmst wenn du das mit unseren
wert werten ernst nimmst das kann es
doch nicht sein dass alle menschen
gleich sind und manche sind ja noch mal
ein bisschen gleicher das geht doch hier
nicht das darf keine königin doch die
kann es meinetwegen gerne geben aber
dann aber die dürfen nicht auslaufen
dann zahlen die erbschaftssteuer und
dann sagen die auch einkommensteuer wie
sich das gehört auf ein teil davon das
hat übrigens
eingeführt auf einen teil davon zahlen
die auch mittlerweile einkommensteuer
aber das glaube ich politisch irgendwann
nicht mehr vermittelbar waren nicht das
jeden falscher eindruck entsteht aber
eben ganz ganz viele ausnahmen ja es
gibt gibt ganz ganz viele gesetze und
das ist sozusagen der nächste punkt bei
dem die königliche familie wirklich
unmittelbar einfluss nimmt
bis zu 160 gesetz die genießen
weitreichende immunität bei ganz vielen
dingen der seit seit den 60er jahren ist
das so da gibt es zum beispiel 30
verschiedene gesetze die es der polizei
untersagen die privaten anwesen balmoral
zum beispiel ohne die erlaubnis der
königin zu betreten um irgendwelche
verbrechen zu untersuchen zum beispiel
will der reihe und wird seine größte
diplomatische staat
umweltverschmutzung man das klingt zu
banal aber sie natürlich nicht banal das
heißt die polizei muss die persönliche
zustimmung des königs jetzt in dem fall
einfach erholen bevor sie zum beispiel
in welche straftaten in welchen privaten
lachs oder forellen fisch unternehmen in
schottland untersucht und du würdest
sagen also wenn ich dich richtig
verstehe man könnte doch mal drei
viertel dieser privilegien streichen und
von diesen ganzen fonds von denen die
sich ernähren
könnte man auch den ein oder anderen
abschaffen und dann würde man die
institution beibehalten aber man würde
die finanziellen mal kräftig abspecken
erst so ganz zufrieden
weißt du ich bin kanadischer mensch ich
hatte heute darum geht es mir nicht mehr
gericht darum nehme an das lag ließ und
darum zu sagen was dieses theater
förderung so kostet das auch nicht nee
das ist nicht mein thema weil die
generieren die auch wahnsinnig viele
einnahmen muss man auch mal sagen das
ist ja ein sich selbst erhaltendes
system also durch die tatsache dass die
da sind diese königliche familie die
sind ja quasi ihre eigene marke john
deere und die und die familie reichlich
gebrauch von nummer so haben sie recht
und
und die verdienen geld ja und und das
ist natürlich interessant für den
tourismusstandort london wenn dort
buckingham palast steht und diese
königliche familie es gibt noch eine
echte königin und so das war für die
natürlich interessant das bringt geld
aber ich finde wenn es um die frage geht
sozusagen genießen ausgerechnet die den
es so gut geht genießen die privilegien
die alle anderen nicht genießen dann
habe ich damit ein problem also vor
allem die rechtlichen prix wie die
rechnungsstellung ist zum beispiel ja
genau also diesen job wahnsinnig weit
gehende immunität staat ja das ist das
eine aber auch die frage nach nach nach
steuern ja wenn andere 40 prozent
erbschaftssteuer zahlen müssen und du
sagst dann schmilzt das unternehmen die
butter in der sonne ja gute alternative
sondern auch ja dass der punkt und und
da glaube ich entsteht so ein frust und
da merken werden so alte freunde
einfach wirklich bewahrt es gibt ja den
greens consent das ist sozusagen so ein
obskures verfahren mit dem hoch bezahlt
der anwälte der königlichen familie
gesetzgebung beeinflussen und die können
gesetze überprüfen die sie betreffen
könnten bevor dann das parlament diese
gesetze genehmigen kann ja das sind
alles so relikte aus der zeit als sich
eines ist ja merkwürdig ich meine der
offiziell hat das englische königshaus
ja nun wirklich sehr wenig macht aber
diese ganzen privilegien das sind der
noch relikte aus der zeit als die könige
noch richtig macht hatten also als
konstitutionelle monarchie bedeutete
dass es tatsächlich noch
verfügungsgewalt gibt die im königshaus
laden ja und da sind die privilegien
einfach übrig geblieben und die sind
irgendwie nie weggenommen worden so der
wurmfortsatz
oder der blinddarm
ausnahmen die verbieten den mitarbeitern
der königin
beschwerden wegen sexueller oder zum
beispiel rassistischer diskriminierung
zu verfolgen ja das gibt das gibt es das
betrifft das wlan stimmen ziemlich bald
also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass das in heutigen zwei jahren
angepasst ja aber das sind so dinge die
es gibt ja das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz in england
jan muss andere gesetze den teilten so
sonder regelungen die die königin dann
als arbeitgeberin von der einhaltung
verschiedener arbeitnehmerrechte
gesundheitssicherheit rentengesetz
befreien warum das verstehe ich nicht
gibt es denn eigentlich überall diese
themen in großbritannien debatten ja
benötigt damit beschäftigt an christa
das auch mit und es gibt so 20 25
prozent der briten stehen
uneingeschränkt sind da kritisch der
große teil 80 prozent der briten sagt
ungefähr
wunderbares wie die haben aber 20
prozent dieser hose und eine kritische
masse die immer wieder diese frage
aufwirft und interessanterweise wenn du
dann in die jüngeren
bevölkerungsschichten guckst unter
jungen leuten da ist das noch viel viel
mehr das ist dann bis zur hälfte und
noch mehr die sagen wir brauchen wir das
eigentlich noch und warum haben die vor
allen dingen diese privilegien
ein beispiel
dieses
diskriminierungsgesetz ja die können
nicht klagen das geht auf die späten
60er jahre zurück als höflinge der die
ministerin sagte dass es nicht üblich
sei ich zitiere farbige einwanderer oder
auswanderer zu ernennen für büro posten
im königlichen haushalt naja so das ist
so das thema dahinter einer bösen
relikte genau
meinst du und dass die menschen jetzt
gerade oder dass die idee das königshaus
hätte war und die in historischen moment
verpasst hat um zu sagen nach der
königin ist schluss also was wäre denn
wenn das königshaus selber gesagt hat
okay wir passen nicht so richtig in die
zeit und das hat sich alles mit der
queen verbunden und das waren die ganze
wilde zeit vom zweiten weltkrieg an und
so weiter aber jetzt sind wir im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert und jetzt
erfinden wir mal das königtum neu und
jetzt nehmen wir mal in erheblichen teil
dieser privilegien beck hätte so eine
initiative von charles ausgehen sollen
meinst du
traust du vielleicht hat er sich
richtung denken musste ich ja selber
abschaffen also das ist ja abschaffen
vielleicht nicht aber auf den teppich
zurückholen
ja
ich weiß gar nicht ob die zeit dafür
reif ist wenn du wenn du siehst was das
für ein mediales spektakel jetzt auch
ist dann habe ich das gefühl also wir
sind weiter entfernt denn je und ich
möchte auch immer sagen anteil des
vielen geldes das die kriegen ist ja
auch schmerzensgeld dafür dass du jeden
zweiten tag in der neuen post stehst ne
kann also das ist das gehört ja auch
dazu genommen sie weitere 2 wird im
zweifelsfall würde der yellow press
journalismus der welt das königshaus
bezahlen dafür dass es weiterhin ziel
hier glaubt das team laufen ja genau und
es gibt ja immer diese argumente zu
sagen na ja gut die die kosten viel geld
sie genießen wahnsinnig viele
privilegien aber auf der anderen seite
muss man ja auch sagen wir haben ja was
davon ja die hohlen touristen nach
england usw das heißt die einnahmen
übersteigen die ausgaben für diese
königliche familie quasi bei weitem da
würde ich aber immer sagen das ist
mittelmäßig gutes argument die hat der
meistbesuchte königliche palast der welt
ist wahr sei
soweit ich weiß war schon immer klar
trennen was sie meinen also das ist so
das ist kein gutes argument also die
schlösser toter könige könnten wir haben
bringen als die lebendigen ist so gutes
beispiel auf ein schönes beispiel das
stück ja dabei dem buckingham palace
kann man gar nicht verdächtigen oder
einen teil davon glaube ich kann man
besichtigen wirklich naja ich glaube ja
uns da war ich auch mal in unser kastl
ist beeindruckend
naja ich habe mich ja viel mit königs
berichterstattung aufgehalten die in
jüngeren jahren weiß ja also das jüngste
schloss was ich in england gesehen habe
ist hampton court das kennt das war das
schloss heinrichs des achten das ist
sehr wichtig erachte diese ein richter
achte und das ist in der nähe von
greenwich soll ich also vor den toren
londons und das ist so ein wunderbarer
renaissance bau mit einem ganz
großartigen garten hat ihre garten und
so weiter das so riecht wie seine kinder
fantasie also wenn man nicht weiß dass
wir ein blutiger herrscher dort war
kommt einem das unglaublich lieblich und
verspielt vor
und so ist das am ende kommen touristen
na ja also erst herrscht also ein
blutiger könig und irgendwann ist es
eine nette touristenattraktion ja ganz
genau
also ich weiß was was sozusagen daraus
weiterhin steht die frage was bedeutet
all das für für ein stadler wenn du wenn
du da jemanden hast der sehr solche
privilegien genießt der sich nicht in
allen gesetzen zu unterwerfen hat den
sich andere zu unterwerfen haben was
bedeutet das eigentlich für so eine
demokratie das ist eine schwierige
geschichte und wenn du anfängst darüber
nachzudenken
kommt man finde ich ganz schnell auf den
punkt und darüber wollte ich mit dir
auch mal kurz rein ich habe das konzept
des nationalstaats nein also das gebilde
in dem wir heute unterwegs sind
ist das nicht auch etwas von dem man
sagen muss möglicherweise ist das bald
völlig überholt wenn du mal überlegt was
dieses deutschland eigentlich ist ich
meine was was verbindet uns die wir hier
in diesem land leben das ist doch
eigentlich nur die tatsache dass wir
sozusagen die gleichen schuhe pflichten
haben dass wir die gleiche sprache
sprechen dass wir die gleichen medien
konsumieren das weil es das überhaupt
noch so ist ja weiß dass über musik ist
genau dass wir
das so die wetterkarte und die tanzshow
hinten deutschland zusammen das ist aber
schon relativ lange nicht mehr der fall
das ist der punkt das heißt und und wenn
du mal anfängst zu überlegen meine
deutsch sein du denkst das ist um so ein
großes starkes gebilde
identitätsstiftend usw aber die
allermeisten menschen die hier in diesem
land von sich sagen wir sind deutsche
die kennst du noch gar nicht dass der
überhaupt keine beziehung zu denen du
hast nichts mit ihnen zu tun es gibt nur
ein paar dünne pendler die uns quasi
zusammenhalten ja also ich habe genauso
gedacht wie du bist vor ungefähr acht
jahren
und dann hatte ich eine sendung mit
klaus von dohnanyi denen ich genau das
gleiche gefragt habe ok und der damals
ein plädoyer für nationalstaaten
gehalten hat das so überzeugend war dass
ich von meiner ansicht abgerückt bin
okay was kann man sich natürlich prozent
hat jetzt kein völkisches argument
gebracht ja da also nicht gesagt wir
sind ein volk seit 1000 jahren und so
weiter und so weiter also das wäre auch
eine argumentation die wir ja das eine
oder andere mehr hören und nicht gefolgt
werde ich niemals gefolgt wäre sondern
gesagt habe das passt nicht mehr ins 21
natur begriffe von volk die haben hier
nichts mehr verloren ja dafür sind wir
zu sehr globale einheits zivilisation
geworden und dieses völkische stammt
eben auch aus einer ganz anderen epoche
und das brauchen wir nicht mehr
mein argument war ja auch immer wir
leben in einer europäischen
einheitsquote mit kleinen nuancen schön
dass es die kleinen nuancen gibt ja dass
man immer noch sagen kann der
durchschnittliche italiener ist
vielleicht ein bisschen anders als der
durchschnittliche norweger ja aber im
grunde genommen guckt man dieselben
netflix serien und man ist dasselbe
globalisierte essen aus aller herren
länder und so weit das hat sich alles im
trägt dieselbe mode das hat sich ja das
angeglichen und dann fragt man sich
warum gibt es so was wie diese
historisch mal durch ungezählte kriege
und verhandlungen und heiratspolitik
entstanden den nationalstaaten auf die
ja gar nicht so alt sind die gar nicht
so alt sind weil eigentlich ist der
nationalstaat 1 erfolgs idee des 19
jahrhunderts mit dem ziel
einheitliche binnenmärkte zu schaffen es
geht um das ist der grund es ging um
wirtschaft es ging um wirtschaft also
lange deutschland so ein flickenteppich
war ja wo über eine zollgrenze war wo
überall anderes geld bewahren konnte aus
diesem deutschland ökonomisch nichts
werden das heißt also der die bismarcks
einigung deutschlands hatte ein ganz
ganz starkes ökonomisches motiv einen
einheitlichen wirtschaftsraum zu
schaffen und man hat ja gesehen dass hat
man halt die franzosen vorher schon
gemacht und die engländer vorher schon
gemacht und überall im 19 jahrhundert
italien garibaldi und so weiter gibt ja
überall wird der bürgerlich mal mit
konstitutionelle monarchie mal ohne
nationalstaat geschafft aber überlegt
man nun mal ganz kurz ihn einfach nur
ein ganz kleiner einwurf nur also wir
nehmen das so als selbstverständlich hin
ja für uns gibt es diese länder für uns
gibt es deutschland italien frankreich
ist alles da aber die wahrheit ist die
allermeiste zeit hatten wir das nicht
richtig die allermeiste zeit hat mir
relativ kleine bilder von ein paar
ausnahmen abgesehen also russland war
jahrhunderte hinweg immer riesen gebilde
zur zeit seit den zeiten iwans des
schrecklichen das schon sehr lange her
aber hätte ich mal in deutschland
bestand aus lauter kleinen gebildet und
jetzt könnte man auch ein plädoyer für
klein gebilde halten kann sagen so
kleine staaten
die haben diesen zusammenhang stärker
als große staaten
zumindest brauchen sie keine kriege für
den zusammenhalt also die usa ist auch
ein land mit einer sehr starken
zusammenhalts patriotismus der aber
unter der oberfläche wir haben ganz oft
darüber gesprochen total bröckelt nun
der ganz häufig immer wieder auch durch
durch kriege kriege zusammengehalten
worden ist erst durch kriege im inland
und dann nachher kriege nach außen und
dann gibt es doch schöne länder wie
dänemark 9 die haben schon sehr lange
keine kriege mehr geführt da gibt es ja
auch glaube ich nur so um die vier
millionen gehen das ist noch so eine
einheit die würde als als identitäts
einheit halbwegs funktionieren so klein
sie überschaubar ist südtirol
funktioniert wahrscheinlich
als südtiroler hat sehr kleinen gebildet
natürlich an der gewinn schwächer so
jetzt könnte man sagen eigentlich müsste
ja die tendenz zur regionalisierung geht
ja nur meine gedanke war immer warum
kürzen wir nicht die nationalstaat eben
raus wir haben oft für die großen dinge
verteidigungspolitik zum halleluja
europa und für für für die seelen heimat
ja und für das regeln des
kleingedruckten habe regionen
und da hatte dohnányi argumentiert dass
er gesagt hat es gibt ganz viele
veränderungen die nur gehen wenn man so
in etwa die größe eines nationalstaats
hat ich nehme ein beispiel das gut
altona nimmt ja das tun von donanimhaber
dohnanyi stammt aber dass somit parallel
beschäftigt ja ich habe mich früher
immer gefragt warum kann man nicht die
massentierhaltung abschaffen oder die
käfighaltung für die noch entzogen und
dann hab ich immer festgestellt okay das
ist alles europäisch und alles was
letztlich europäisch geregelt ist kann
man nicht mehr richtig verändern das
heißt dieses europa das sich ja
grundsätzlich befürwortet ist zugleich
immer wieder ob man will oder nicht der
versuch etwas in zement zu diesen was
man nicht in zement gießen darf das
heißt man friert gesellschaftliche
zustände ein wenn man wie die zustimmung
von 30 staaten dafür braucht das etwas
geändert werden kann dann wird es nie
mehr geändert das heißt wie sicherheit
brauchst du gerne auf dieses europa
neigt dazu gesellschaftliche dynamiken
nicht aufzunehmen
sondern zu konservieren sondern zu
konservieren und dann nicht mehr fix
bibel zu sein und dann gibt das den
menschen in den ländern das gefühl man
kann nichts mehr ändern was ganz ganz
schlimmes für demokratien wenn die
bevölkerung das gefühl hat man kann
nichts ändern ja dann entsteht dieser
hass auf die da oben und die bürokratie
und brüssel und alles was dazugehört
hast du aber kleinere ebenen die
gleichzeitig handlungsfähig sind also
größer als regionen dafür ist diese
ebene des nationalstaats um
gesellschaftliche dynamik hin zu
entwickeln die dann wiederum nach europa
eingetragen werden natürlich sehr viel
besser als wenn du nur die kleinen
regionen hast und das große statische
unverrückbar europa und das wäre jetzt
quasi das argument für die national
standen also sozusagen diese diese
zwischenebene der zwischenschritt den du
brauchst das ohne die zwischenebene
gesellschaftliche dynamik nicht mehr
funktionieren würde nur noch im kleinen
also unser dorf soll schöner werden und
für die region und wir sind sozusagen
die umweltfreundlichste region europas
das würde alles funktionieren aber
solche sachen wie zum beispiel dass man
das verhältnis schwanger werden gesetze
die frauen betreffen verändern dass man
gesetze verändert die migration
betreffen dass man gesetze verändert die
tiere betreffen das alles wäre nicht
mehr möglich
also ohne die zwischenebene wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht geben und wenn
diese zwischenebene jetzt nicht
aufgeheizt essen aufgetankt es mit
völkisches gedankengut
dann ist sie ja auch an sich nicht
unselig das schöne ist doch ich meine
man könnte noch ein argument bringen was
ist eine fußball-europameisterschaft
noch wert wenn es keine nationale
ja was machen wir aus einem turnier der
region habe also wenn der fc südtirol
dann mal gewinnen würde das wäre
natürlich schon der hätte da eine reale
chance bei ihr nur das wasser wird ein
hoher südtiroler nur gegen bayern und
die gegen rheinländer spielen und so
vielleicht wäre es spannender als
europameisterschaft heute aber die
müsste mal neu erfinden ich komme auf
das argument weil ich mal mit robert
menasse den ich sehr schätze
österreichischer schriftsteller
hoch dekorierte viele preise und der ist
ihm der inbegriff eines im besten sinne
altmodischen intellektuellen und der ist
schriftsteller und denker philosophin
einer person in österreich auch sehr
wichtiger mann und der wollte die
nationalstaaten eigentlich immer
abschaffen und ob es ja immer noch für
und der wollte auch die
fußball-europameisterschaft abschaffen
mit dem hinweis das bringt nur unfrieden
ja das pfeift uns wieder quasi auf
unseren nationen status zurück und ich
habe versucht ihm klar zu machen dass
sport fußball ja der die die möglichkeit
ist diese art von gefühlen vier wochen
lang raus zu lassen um sie dann
anschließend vier jahre wieder nicht
mehr zu brauchen und das ist viel besser
ist solche turniere gegeneinander zu
spielen als kriege gegen kann dann dazu
führen weil das hat man früher gemacht
und das ist wahr also fußball als ersatz
krieg ja ja und das gar nicht zynisch
gemeint sondern wirklich mit viel
sympathie begleitet es gibt ja es gibt
ja wenn du wenn du da mal also dieses
dohnanyi argument ist natürlich ein
wirklich gutes argument es gibt noch ein
anderes argument finde ich also wenn du
überlegst was
was passiert dann was tritt an die
stelle also was war sozusagen das was da
war bevor
nationalstaaten entstanden sind dann
hast du es ja immer zu tun sozusagen mit
ethnischen identitäten oder religiöse
identität also gruppen menschen wir
menschen brauchen das glaube ich wir
brauchen dieses gefühl irgendwo
dazuzugehören genau und dass das schöne
ist ja am 21 jahrhundert dass wir uns
die gruppe zu der wieder zu gehören
wollen mehr und mehr aussuchen können
und den früheren jahrhunderten wo man
sich sein leben nicht aussuchen konnte
konnte man sich nicht aussuchen ja an
welchem platz in der welt war welche
religion mann hatte wo man lebte und da
blieben einem dann so dinge wie volk
oder religion und heute kann man sich
alle erdenklichen gruppen
zugehörigkeiten aussuchen und sogar
parallel sich mit ganz vielen
verschiedenen identifizieren
und das ist ja eine wahnsinnig positive
entwicklung ja eben diesen alten
identifikations gruppen ja die diesen
alleinvertretungsanspruch nimmt das ist
sowas wie parteien wie die afg schwer
mit umgehen können dass es menschen gibt
für die die gruppenzugehörigkeit lässt
wird so seien wichtiger ist als deutsche
zu sein zum beispiel dass man sich das
aussuchen kann was für ein
identitätsstiftender genau und da glaube
ich halt also wenn du zum beispiel oft
in jugoslawien kriegs wenn du dir
anschaust was damals in bosnien passiert
ist ja das war eine religiöse und
ethnische konflikte also dagegen genau
diese gruppierungen aufeinander los und
ich hause hat das nein das kann immer
und immer wieder neu passieren nicht was
wir jetzt in der ukraine und in russland
erleben ja was wir was wir in syrien
haben also das gespenst ja das ist nicht
gebannt ja das gespenst ist auch bei uns
ist das nicht gänzlich weg das meine ich
aber der gedanke war richard zu sagen
und vielleicht ist genau das das war
eben der zweite gedanke zu dem ersten
von dohnanyi dazu vielleicht ist genau
das die rolle des nationalstaates von
dem ja viele sagen wo hat sich
eigentlich erledigt in zeiten der
globalisierung ja wo ist sozusagen die
gemeinsame kultur du erinnerst dich an
die debatten über leitkultur und so
weiter wo ist die gemeinsame sprache wo
ist der gemeinsame kulturelle
hintergrund ja wenn du dir das
deutschland von heute anschaust aus
deutschland von heute haben mit dem
deutschland dass ich kennengelernt habe
anfang der neunziger als ich hergekommen
bin nichts mehr zu tun ja was sind für
dich das finde ich einen super frage was
sind für dich so offen was fällt dir als
erstes ein als ganz große unterschiede
so am anfang der 90er jahre als was war
vor 30 jahren ganz anders wenn du wenn
du durch die fußgängerzone läuft ja also
das ist kein homogenes bild mehr du
siehst einfach menschen aus aller herren
länder das ist der punkt dass das heuer
aufgefallen als ich anfang der 80er
jahre das erste mal in london war ja
exakt ja ich hatte dann auch separate
new york so viele menschen mit dunkler
hautfarbe gesehen so viele immer gesehen
enkel und das war was ich mir so aus dem
was ich konnte die rheinischen
großstädten düsseldorf holen und so
weiter
ganz ganz anders also hinter inzwischen
hat sich das sehr viel stärker
angeglichen das ist genau ja das ist
genau der punkt und was aber was aber
doch also du kannst daraus sozusagen ein
problem bauen und sagen oh wie toll es
schwierig und identität usw du kannst
aber auch sagen ist es nicht eigentlich
großartig dass doch das zusammenleben
von menschen die so viele verschiedene
hintergründe haben die ja auch alle ihre
geschichte mitbringen ja ich meine wenn
du wenn du wenn du aus ländern kommen in
denen gut ein halbes leben nur
bürgerkrieg erlebt hast oder hunger oder
was auch immer dann hast du natürlich
ein ganz anderen rucksack mit dem du
hier ankommst als jemand der hier
vielleicht geboren ist eine völlig
andere geschichte und die kinder dieser
leute um wiederum der andere geschichte
und in dem zusammenhang auch total
interessant ja meine kinder laufen in
der offiziellen deutschen statistik als
kinder mit migrationshintergrund weil
ich in italienischen
pascal migrationshintergrund klar als
wirtschaftsführer aus
der wirtschaft direkt hier oder warst du
in südtirol politisch verfolgt werden
hinein dass das schließlich wirklich aus
ich
bitte das ist ein sehr sehr schönes land
und man kann dort wunderbar leben und es
gibt gleich politisch verfolgten nein
definitiv nein nein aber bitte nach
südtirol hat eine wechselvolle
geschichte wie du weißt ich weiß und und
die frage sozusagen nach identität die
frage wer bist du was mache ich
eigentlich aus wozu fühlst du dich
zugehörig und so weiter das ist
natürlich eine frage die dich
beschäftigt und die musst du auch für
dich klären und interessanterweise wirst
du dann zum patrioten weil du dann
plötzlich irgendwann mit einem kleinen
koffer in einem anderen land ankommst in
deutschland ankommt dann musst du
nämlich deine identität klar ich glaube
es geht dir mit deutschland sowie es
ganz ganz vielen menschen früher immer
mit den usa ging genau dass die
zugewanderten drei jahrzehnte später die
leidenschaftlichsten patrioten also
genauso ja und zwar wie du gerade sagt
natürlich nicht im völkischen sinne ja
aber mit einer starken identifikation
dessen was an einem land wie deutschland
gut ist ja weil es genau weil es da
immer natürlich dieses grundgefühl von
barth gibt ja die chance die du bekommen
hast du hättest du bei dir zu hause so
nicht kriegen können einfach weil das
viel zu klein ist und viel zu
unübersichtlich so schön das auch alles
ist aber das hätte so nicht funktioniert
und deswegen gibt es diese dankbarkeit
aber es ist eben interessant anzusehen
und da hat sich auch glaube ich um
verständnis vieles verändert
die die die sozusagen möglichkeit dass
jemand ein
patriotischer italiener und gleichzeitig
auch ein patriotischer deutsche riss
oder ein patriotischer türke oder und
ein patriotischer deutscher das hat
lange gedauert bis sich das sozusagen
manifestiert hat bis klar war das geht
alles ich jemandem gesagt ich erlebe bei
türken wenn fußball weltmeisterschaft
war und deutschland gegen türkei
gespielt hat ja meine dass ihr erzählt
habe ich immer gestellt krediten wie
aris in ihr herz war ja genau ich kann
mir vorstellen dass du nicht für italien
bist weil du ja südtirol wahrscheinlich
wir alle südtiroler nicht unbedingt als
ein teil italien sieht das oder das kann
man so pauschal nicht sagen das ist das
ist so ich bin da immer sehr neutral
weißt du ich bin da dass das ist ja das
was ich meine du lernst zu verstehen was
gut an ländern ist du lernst zu
verstehen wo die chancen sind ernst zu
verstehen welche welche welche
möglichkeiten die tatsache dass du eben
verschiedene kulturen kennst
verschiedene sprachen kennst
verschiedene lebensgewohnheiten kennst
welche möglichkeiten daraus resultieren
es macht dich flexibel im kopf ja und
gleichzeitig aber ist es etwas das man
als als mehrheitsgesellschaft hier dann
auch akzeptieren muss und sagen muss was
auf
okay der hat sich hier integriert aber
gleichzeitig darf ich ihm nicht das was
er noch sozusagen in seinem rucksack
bringen hat was da noch türkisch ist
oder italienisch ist oder südtiroler
risch ist das darf ich dem nicht
wegnehmen weil das ist natürlich teil
seiner identität und das ist richtig das
zu verstehen aber ist ein total
interessanter punkt sollten wir darüber
reden noch mal abschließend richard
nationalstaaten hast du dieses lied ist
sozusagen diese monarchie der in england
wir haben unsere schöne bundesrepublik
und habe neben mich die queen oder den
den könig so dass auch ihre die
engländer jetzt ein gehört er sagte ich
denke
dass es in der hymne ja nicht mehr heißt
god save the queen ja sodann god save
the king dass das ist auch textlich eine
echte herausforderung her dass irgendwie
hinzukriegen aber diese monarchie
sozusagen versus republik und eben dann
dahingehend nationalstaat glaubst du
dass dieses gebilde nationalstaat dieses
diese diese staatlichkeit wie wir sie
jetzt kennen und die noch nicht so alt
ist ich meine reichsgründung ist nicht
so furchtbar lange her und hatte wie du
grad erzählt dass vor einigen
ökonomische gründe also das ist wenig
was uns da eigentlich in wahrheit so
wirklich zusammenhält
glaubst du dass das wirklich eine
zukunft hat oder ist das etwas von dem
man sagen muss in zeiten der
globalisierung in dem wir uns mehr und
mehr sozusagen als weltgemeinschaft
begreifen oder als europäische
gemeinschaft begreifen ist das in
wahrheit ein auslaufmodell und es wird
irgendwann einen deutschen kanzler mehr
geben und es wird keinen keine
premierminister geben es wird einfach in
brüssel jemanden geben der sagt was auf
wir machen das jetzt hier und das wird
auch einigermaßen funktionieren nur
verteidigung ja weil wir so viel über
die prämie ausgesprochen haben das ist
wahnsinn wir können uns nicht mal auf
einen standard bei munition zum beispiel
einigen tja also da werden ein panzer
gebaut und dann hat jedes land hat seine
eigenen panzer mit der eigenen munition
und es ist völlig grotesk also das kann
so nicht weitergehen
gleichzeitig haben wir schon seit 30
jahren die größe von gruppen normiert
zum beispiel ja also ist er merkwürdig
manchen bereichen sind wir da sofort
ohne not über jedes ziel
hinausgeschossen und in anderen wie wir
gerade sehen hinter mir dieser
entwicklung hinterher ich glaube dass
unseren lebzeiten markus die
nationalstaaten nicht verschwinden
werden also ich glaube das ist ein
nationalstaat ist sein tod gesagt hat er
noch relativ lange leben wird meinst du
ja ja das glaube ich aber ich will jetzt
nur ist muss nicht bedeuten es muss
nicht bedeuten dass die nationalstaaten
die genau gleichen kompetenzen haben
diese jetzt haben also da könnte sich
das eine oder andere noch verändern aber
weiß wovon das abhängt ich hatte ja
vorhin gesagt alles was europäischen
gesetze gefasst wird wird sehr leicht
und sehr schnell instrument gegossen und
ist dann einfach nicht mehr zu verändern
und die hauptvoraussetzung dafür dass
man die ebene des nationalstaats raus
kürzen könnte wäre eine grundlegende
reform der europäischen union
im hinblick auf die möglichkeiten
gesetze zu ändern denn wenn die
europäische union nicht diesbezüglich
demokratischer wird als jetzt ist
und dass diese entscheidung auch nicht
immer mit zu großen mehrheiten
auseinander allein wählen kann und dass
sie nicht so was zum beispiel landwirte
lassen dass die die kommissarin ja dass
die nicht auch so merkwürdige art und
weise ausgeklügelt werden und uns also
es gibt ja einige entschieden
demokratiedefizite auf der ebene das
okay so schön sagen ja die zu beheben
wäre ja erstmal der allererste schritt
bevor man darüber nachdenkt noch
weiterhin kompetenzen die die
nationalstaaten haben an die europäische
ebene zu delegieren ja so du hast
wahrscheinlich recht ich meine letzter
gedanke noch
mich erinnert das immer an lothar de
maizière ich hab mit dem mehrfach
die chance gehabt interviews zu machen
und diesen mann zu sprechen denn ich für
eine ganz faszinierende figuren der
deutschen politik halte und er hat mir
das auch nur selbst so gesagt er sagte
wissen sie mein job als letzter
ministerpräsident der ddr war im
wesentlichen mich selbst abzuschaffen
und thomas von de maizière lernen heißt
siegen lernen wie ich meine im hinblick
auf das auf prinz charles der sich
nebeneinander im hinblick auf alle
regierungschefs zu beispiele in dieser
europäischen union also wer außer lothar
de maizière wäre noch bereit sich
demnächst selber abzuschaffen das ist
die frage und ich habe nicht viel
hoffnung dass eine große schwere frage
nach der sicherheit vielen dank das hat
spaß gemacht ja demnächst reden wir
darüber was an deutschland gut ist und
über viele weitere themen das war heute
spannend ich als hardcore royalisten zu
erleben das hätte ich nicht für möglich
keiten ja so ist das sowas ja gleich am
anfang
weiter im alter werden sie alle
reaktionäre frage war also
alles liebe
[Musik]
eine produktion von m2 und popstars bei
ohren er im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]